Trascrizione: Sara Mattesini
Revisore: Beatrice Ricci
Buonasera a tutti.
Io oggi vi parlo brevemente
di un tubicino,
del contenuto di questo tubicino;
e di tre cucchiai.
Il tubicino è l'idea,
e i tre cucchiai sono i tre equilibri
che hanno consentito a quest'idea
di passare dal banco di un laboratorio
a diventare una multinazionale.
Non è niente a che vedere
con la tecnologia, la ricerca;
riguarda quello che abbiamo dentro,
è il nostro essere uomini e donne
e come li gestiamo.
Gli equilibri sono le nostre emozioni.
È quello che ho imparato
da questa esperienza.
E non ha niente a che vedere neanche
con i finanziamenti o il danaro.
Viviamo in un periodo di crisi,
lo dicono tutti,
c'è stata la crisi anche in passato
e ci sarà in futuro.
Ma io una cosa l'ho imparata per certa:
ci sono molti più soldi che buone idee.
E quindi volevo un attimo raccontarvi
di quale è questa esperienza.
L'idea era diciamo, a raccontarla,
abbastanza semplice;
farlo è stato un po' più complicato.
15 anni fa avevo ancora i capelli
(Risate)
e venne da noi, al dipartimento,
una multinazionale che vendeva pannolini
e prodotti assorbenti
per l'igiene personale
e ci disse:
"Abbiamo l'idea di fare un pannolino
completamente biodegradabile."
Fare il pannolino biodegradabile
è abbastanza facile,
tranne per il materiale interno
che è un super assorbente.
Un materiale come questo,
che ho gettato adesso nel bicchiere,
che è in grado di assorbire
anche un litro d'acqua
per grammo di materiale secco.
Loro volevano fare il pannolino
completamente biodegradabile
e noi dovevamo fare
il super assorbente interno.
E lo facemmo.
Però lì mi scontrai
con il primo dei tre equilibri.
Li raffiguro con i tre cucchiai.
Volevo preparare delle slide,
però ho pensato che così
forse è più immediato.
Il primo equilibrio è tra infatuazione
e amore.
L'infatuazione è innamorarsi
di una cosa per come è,
amore è amare una cosa per come cambia.
Sono sicuro che quanti di voi in sala
sono innamorati di una donna, di un uomo,
sono innamorati per come cambia nel tempo.
Darwin disse che la specie che sopravvive
è quella che più facilmente
si adatta al cambiamento.
All'inizio, un ricercatore, un inventore
ha sempre l'infatuazione.
La mia fu questa.
(Applausi)
Io ero infatuato,
non amavo questo materiale.
Vedevo pannolini biodegradabili
in giro per il mondo,
mamme felici e bambini che sorridevano,
niente più rifiuti nelle città.
Mi fu rotta un pomeriggio d'inverno,
quando il presidente della multinazionale
venne a Napoli e disse:
"Sai che c'è di nuovo?
Questo brevetto che hai fatto
ce lo mettiamo nel cassetto,
non lo utilizziamo."
Come?
"No, ci sarebbe un costo troppo elevato
per andare sul mercato.
Noi vogliamo solo fare sapere
ai nostri competitor che ce l'abbiamo."
Mi arrabbiai tantissimo.
Però capii che io dovevo fare
qualcos'altro con questo materiale.
E allora cercammo di capire
come cambiava questo materiale.
Quali erano le altre applicazioni?
Pensammo all'agricoltura,
al rilascio di acqua e nutrienti
in zone aride e deserte
nel Mezzogiorno d'Italia.
Facemmo anche delle prove.
Difficile andare sul mercato.
Prodotti per la dialisi:
assorbono l'acqua dall'intestino
e così diminuiscono il contenuto
d'acqua da eliminare in dialisi.
Sperimentazioni sull'uomo molto lunghe.
Fino a che ero a Boston,
e un gruppo di investitori si accorse
che con questo materiale
si poteva fare una cosa banale:
oltre ad essere biodegradabile,
si poteva mangiare.
Era un'unicità.
Utilizzalo come superassorbente
bulking agent per diete ipocaloriche:
lo ingerisci, si gonfia nello stomaco
e dà senso di sazietà.
È cambiato tante volte questo materiale
e questo è stato il primo cambiamento:
capire che la prima applicazione
della quale ci si infatua
non è la vera applicazione
che può andare sul mercato.
Oggi questa è diventata un'impresa
ormai multinazionale.
Secondo equilibrio:
vado veloce, perché il tempo è tiranno.
Il secondo equilibrio
è tra paura e specializzazione.
All'inizio, avevamo tanta paura,
ma veramente tanta.
Dopo l'infatuazione, appunto, iniziale
che dà tanto entusiasmo,
"Ma sì, sarà una grande impresa!",
viene la paura.
Paura che la cosa possa non andare bene,
che le persone investano
tanti soldi e magari li deludi.
Paura delle prime sperimentazioni,
che vanno male.
E infatti, i primi investitori
ci lasciarono per questo,
perché non c'era
una specializzazione sufficiente
per capire che questo
prodotto era vincente.
Però, avere paura è importante.
Perché se si ha paura, vuol dire
che si crede veramente in quella cosa,
che ci si tiene parecchio.
E io ne ho avuta tanta, di paura.
Forse ne ho ancora abbastanza.
Però, vincere questa paura
è l'aspetto fondamentale.
Vincerla con la specializzazione.
Io l'unica cosa che sapevo -
non sapevo fare impresa,
non la so fare neanche adesso -
però conoscevo molto bene
questo materiale.
E così fummo in grado
di cambiarlo, ancora una volta,
per poterlo portare sul mercato.
Gli investitori nuovi che entravano
conoscevano molto bene il mercato.
Se ti chiedono di fare
un salto nel vuoto, tu non lo fai.
Ma se ti dicono che oltre quel vuoto
c'è una pedana molto solida
e te la fanno anche vedere,
tu vai con loro.
E il loro profilo di rischio si abbassa.
E quindi bisogna vincere
il secondo equilibrio
e far diventare la paura
forte della sua specializzazione.
Il terzo equilibrio
è tra fallimento e successo.
Nella nostra società,
nel nostro modo di vivere molto rapido,
queste due cose sembrano
completamente separate.
In realtà sono la stessa cosa.
Negli Stati Uniti dicono
che un imprenditore
non è un vero imprenditore
se non fallisce almeno tre volte.
Io sono un grandissimo fallito.
Io ho fallito tante volte.
Ho fallito con i pannolini,
ho fallito con l'agricoltura.
Provai a fare anche
dei giocattolini, con questo gel.
Il successo è capire
l'importanza del fallimento.
E chiudo con questo aneddoto.
Quando dovemmo scegliere il responsabile
della sperimentazione sull'uomo,
il nostro amministratore delegato disse:
"Ragazzi, grande successo.
Siamo riusciti a prendere un responsabile
del fallimento del Rimonanbant",
un farmaco che ha speso 200 milioni
e fallito in fase tre.
Tutti ad applaudire, e io pensavo:
"Questi son pazzi, sono sul Truman Show."
E invece no.
Quella persona ci ha traghettato
fino al successo
della nuova multinazionale.
È per questo che dico,
a tutti i giovani di età e di spirito:
"Non abbiate paura
della vostra giovinezza,
confrontatevi con i fallimenti,
perché come disse
un vecchio professore di chimica,
"I giovani sono come le rondini:
fanno una gran confusione,
ma volano sempre verso la primavera".
Grazie.
(Applausi)